Die Berliner Familie Burgdorff
nach einem Jahr Corona:
Alle sind zu Hause,
alle beschäftigt am Computer –
okay, fast alle.
Leandro kämpft mit Mathematik.
Der 14-Jährige sitzt bis zu
neun Stunden am Tag am Laptop:
knallvoller Stundenplan plus Hausaufgaben.
Leandro muss sich manchmal
selbst zum Homeschooling zwingen.
Man wird halt traurig, man hat halt ...
man hat halt keine Lust mehr zu nichts.
Man kriegt sozusagen ’nen ...
schon fast so ’n bisschen depressiv sein.
Also, das ist natürlich ein großes Wort,
depressiv sein, aber schon fast!
Also, das ist krass. Man wird traurig,
man ... will nichts mehr machen.
Auch Mutter Paola ist im Homeschooling.
Sie ist Lehrerin und will die Kinder
endlich wieder in der Schule unterrichten.
Die Corona-Impfung würde das erleichtern.
Aber auf die Impfung muss Paola warten, bis
sie angeschrieben wird.
Ich habe gestern eine Nachricht bekommen
von meiner Schule, dass
die Einladungen für Impfungen für meine
Kollegen, für mich per Post kommen,
und das ist eine ...
für mich persönlich eine sehr gute Nachricht,
dann weiß ich, ich habe einen Impftermin.
Die Impfungen kommen nur
schleppend voran in Deutschland.
Erst zehn Prozent der Bevölkerung sind
geimpft:
die Menschen über 80, das Personal in
Krankenhäusern und Pflegeheimen.
Paola Burgdorff kann sich nicht einfach in
eine Schlange vorm Impfzentrum einreihen.
Sie bereitet sich jetzt auf die lang
ersehnten Schnelltests in der Schule vor.
Bald soll es auch in ihrer Schule losgehen.
Selbsttests machen die Schule sicherer,
aber in Deutschland sind
die Tests noch immer Mangelware.
Paola sorgt sich, dass sie
den Kontakt zu ihren Schülern verliert.
Und es kommt nichts zurück,
also weder „Nein, ich habe keine Lust“
oder „Ja, mache ich“, sondern gar nichts.
Und da macht man sich natürlich
Gedanken: Wo sind sie eigentlich?
Vater Marc hat sich sein Homeoffice
im Schlafzimmer eingerichtet.
Besser als das, findet er:
In der Pandemie mit Bus und Bahn
zur Arbeit fahren, das gilt als riskant.
Aber im europäischen Vergleich
ist Deutschland nur Durchschnitt
in der Homeoffice-Nutzung –
mit unter 40 Prozent der Beschäftigten.
Aber auch zu Hause sieht
sich Marc ziemlich herausgefordert.
Das ist doch anspruchsvoll manchmal,
die berufliche Gedankenwelt
und die berufliche Aura,
die einen da umgibt,
und [die] dann mit Kind, Hund,
Frau zu Hause zu verbinden,
das ist manchmal ’ne sportliche
Gesamtmischung.
Gedanklich beschäftigt sich Marc
mit der Zukunft nach der Pandemie.
Er leitet ein Start-up mit Ideen für einen neuen
Tourismus nach der Corona-Krise.
Und alle zusammen sind
die Burgdorffs sehr dankbar,
dass sie bis jetzt gesund durch die
Pandemie gekommen sind.